paparmi les déchets, que dort
AhAhmed depuis quelques jours.
C'C'est loin des conditions de e
dodont il rêvavait en rejoignant
CeCeuta depuis le Maroc à la a ,
lulundi dernier.
L La grande majorité des quelqe
808000 migrants, des Marocains
susurtout, ont été renvoyés dans
leleur pays par les autorités
esespagnoles. Mais Ahmed espèree
ararriver à f fuir les policiers
popour rejoindre le continent
eueuropéen.
A Abdullah h a 14 ans. Il est
ararrivé ici avec ses compagnons
dede jeux après s avoir entendu
susur les réseaux sociaux que
lala frontièrere était ouverte.
IlIl dit avoir frappé aux portes
dedes centres d'hébergement
ououverts dans des entrepôtsts
dédésaffectés et des gymnases
àà C Ceuta, mais avec plus
dede 800 enfants hébergés,
ilils affichent complet.
I Ils sont encore nombreux,
ceces jeunes mineurs, à t traînr
dadans les parcs et autour
dedes centres commerciaux.
AÀ s'accrocher, comme Yassine,
1616 ans, à c cet idéal d'une ve
ouoù ils seraient respectés,
coconsidérés.
L Les problèmemes de migration
ilillégale ne sont pas nouveaux
àà Ceueuta. La ville espagnole,
enenclavée sur les côtess
mamarocaines de la Méditerranée,
esest une cible de choix pour cx
ququi ne voient d'autre avenir
ququ'un avenir européen.
M Mais jamais Ceuta n'avait
coconnu un tel raz-de-marée.
LaLa population ici est composée
àà 5 50 % de chrétiens et 50 %
dede musulmans. La crise actuele
titire très s fort sur les fils
ququi retiennent le tissu socia,
seselon le vice-président de la
viville, qui parle d'une invasi.
- - Somos españoles! Y nos
momoriremos siendo españoles!
- - Un équilibre fragile
etet des tensions ravivées par
lala venue du chef de Vox,
unun parti d'extrêmeme droite.
IlIl avait annononcé
unun rassemblement de
seses partisans au centre-ville.
LaLa justice, citant des raisons
dede sécurité, a fait interdirea
mamanifestation, mais le diriget
popolitique s'est entêté..
(s(slogans)
C C'est dononc à c coup d'insus
cocomme "raciste", "fasciste",
"p"provocateur" et quelques
obobscénités qui se passent de
trtraduction que Santiago Abascl
a a été accueilli par
ceces contre-manifestants.
(s(slogans)
S Si l'interdiction par
unun tribunal n'aura pas fait
chchanger d'avis le dirigeant
dudu parti Vox ici pour
unune deuxièmeme fois en une see
àà peieine, la colèrere de
ceces manifestants, elle,
auaura finalement eu raison
dede ses plans.
(s(slogans)
C C'est plutôt t à l'i'intériee
soson hôtetel, protégé de la coe
dedes manifestants par un cordon
popolicier, que Santiago Abascal
fefera une déclaration
àà l la presse.
P Pour ceux qui sont venus,
c'c'est un drame humain qui
sese joue bien loin des crises
popolitiques. Un espoir dérobé
popour plusieurs, une déception
amamère p pour d'autres qui
n'n'attendent plus qu'on leur
momontre la porte. Ils repartent
cocomme ils sont venus, mais
bebeaucoup retenterons leur chae
susur ces quelques centaines
dede mètreses qui les séparenent
dede leurs aspirations.
I Ici Marie-Eve Bédard,
R Radio-Canada, à Ceueuta,
e en Espagne.